Marvel's most powerful being explained
I.E the crown not the one above all
let's make this make sense so the nature
of cosmic entities in Marvel Comics as a
lot of you guys probably already know
they exist on a universal level and a
multiversal level Universal level Cosmic
entities are like eternity Infinity
Master order Lord Chaos on the
multiversal level you have like the
Living Tribunal and the beyonders kind
of the Marquee of death Clyde wincham to
a degree and so on and so forth but
historically above them all you had the
one above all which makes sense it's
literally its name the reason why this
matters so much all goes back to the
events leading up to Secret Wars in 2015
and the events that came after so as
most of you guys know from Secret Wars
2015 specifically Jonathan Hickman's run
on Avengers and New Avengers the
greatest comic story ever told the
incursions were happening the Multiverse
was collapsing the end was not Loki was
actually able to escape the collapse of
the Multiverse by leaving all space in
time during that time period he caught a
glimpse of this being called Enigma and
that was about the extent of it at that
point now this all goes into a comic
called Defenders Beyond by Al ying and
this was basically a team composed of
like Adam verer the blue Marvel Monica
Rambo I think America Chavez was on it I
can't remember off top of my head but in
effect this team was assembled by The
Cosmic entity eternity and their job was
to go into the Multiverse and figure out
what Enigma was learn any Poss possible
weaknesses it may have and how to
exploit those weaknesses to destroy it
because what Enigma was doing was
traveling from one Universe to the next
and basically absorbing it consuming it
destroying it the way the galatis
consumes and destroys worlds suffice it
to say all we really learned about
Enigma was two things number one it was
represented in the form of a crown
transitioning through realities number
two that it is more powerful than the
one above all and the reason why is that
as part of aling's restructuring ing of
the Marvel Cosmic hierarchy he
established that the one above all is
not alone in its existence that in fact
it represents or is part of a whole new
order of cosmic entities that we simply
didn't know about before transitioning
away from Defenders Beyond and focusing
on the here in now let's talk about how
the X-Men brings it all together so in
Marvel Comics beginning with Jonathan
Hickman's House of X running all the way
up until now what we had learned is that
there was just a guy in the world named
Nathaniel Essex and he has his own
history and all that kind of stuff but
this guy had come to the realization
that somewhere along the line humanity
is going to achieve a technological
singularity and when that happens a
group of beings out there called the
failinks which are in of themselves
their own dominion basically a
technological hive mind that they are
going to show up on Earth they're going
to absorb all sentient life into
themselves which will in effect destroy
all life on Earth and so in order to
prevent that from happening Nathaniel
Essex cloned himself three times and
then made a clone of his wife right
these clones came in the form of Dr
stasis orbis Stellaris mother righteous
and then Sinister as we've always known
him with the diamond on his head the
purpose of these four clones was to find
a way to achieve Dominion Hood basically
this kind of
unspecified godlevel power right that
Marvel's introduced very Ambiguously
what these four didn't know is that they
were actually Pawns in a game being
played by the original Nathaniel essics
which we'll talk about that here in a
second because he is in effect the
Enigma Dominion so talking about these
four clones what's going on in the X-Men
Comics right now and their connection
with the Enigma Dominion that each of
these four people basically were tasked
with trying to find some level of
godhood through different aspects of the
Marvel Universe mother righteous focused
on Magic hence the reason why she has so
many dealings or at least is aware more
so than any of the other Sinister clones
about like doctor strange and the
Scarlet w and all the magical principles
in Marvel Comics Dr stasis focuses on
technology and that's the reason why he
works so close with orcus that Sinister
with the diamond on his head focuses on
the mutants and that orbit staris
focuses on the Cosmic Landscape and so
with each one of these sinisters
focusing on each one of these
Specialties their goal was to find a
level of power within their own
discipline that was so Advanced that
they could achieve godhood what we found
out in rise of powers of X is that what
was actually happening is that none of
them were ever going to be successful
the reason why is because all the
information they were gaining about all
these different disciplines was all
being sent back to a central location
being sent back to the Nathaniel Essex
Ai and what it was doing was
consolidating all this information and
picking out the little things that it
needed in order to understand how to
achieve godhood and so in effect they
were creating the Enigma Dominion not
realizing they were creating the Enigma
Dominion now here's where things get
crazy right once the Enigma Dominion
came online in the same way that like
Skynet came online during Terminator it
achieved this level of godhood and took
off outside of all space in time and so
it was like witnessing the entire
Multiverse on the outside the same way
that Loki Witnesses the Multiverse at
the end of Loki season 2 for those of
you guys who have seen that show but
let's say and let's kind of stick with
that example right Loki at the end of
season 2 let's say that Loki a little
uncertain about whether or not things
would unfold the way they were supposed
to that would lead to him sitting on the
chair holding all the universes that
what he did is he went through the main
Marvel Cinematic Universe and started
manipulating small little things here
and there to ensure that everything
happened the way it was supposed to so
he would end up on that chair and that's
what the Enigma Dominion did that
existing outside of all of space and
time it created itself in the form of an
AI that could gather all information
that the other four clones were
gathering and they would in effect
create it so it's very circular right it
comes into existence and then it
solidifies its own existence if that
really kind of blows your mind it's
completely Fair it is a little overly
complicated but that's the nature of
this right it's the reason why the
Dominion is so astronomically powerful
it exists outside all of space and time
and it's part of a higher order of
cosmic entities Beyond even the one
above all or any of the cosmic entities
we've seen so far now the question that
has to be asked here is can it only be
achieved through basically a combination
of all forms of knowledge and power
within a particular Universe I.E almost
like assembling the Infinity Stones from
The Infinity Gauntlet or can a person
just achieve a level of power that will
let them do that we don't have the
answer to that question very little is
known about all of this other than what
I've explained here over time that may
or may not be fleshed out but with that
being said guys let me know if you have
any questions down in the comment
section I'll do my best to answer them
and I will catch you all later
peace